nous sommes avec danielle babin avocate
au barreau de paris bonjour merci d'être
avec nous ce matin vous avez pris vous
avez beaucoup défendent et de nombreux
migrants
d'abord qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce
rapport du ministère de l'intérieur qui
montre justement que les l'augmentation
toujours croissante du nombre de
demandeurs d'asile en france
ben écoute et c'est tout à fait objectif
je pense que la problématique du droit
d'asile en france va avec
en fait un monde qui est en pleine
mutation le droit d'asile cet endroit
qu'ils se réforment au fil des
gouvernements qui se succèdent et je
dirais que la montée actuelle de la
migration vers vers l'europe est aussi
la conséquence manifeste de plusieurs
de plusieurs situations je dirais tant
au plan économique politique que que
climatique
c'est à dire que l'asile à plusieurs
raisons aujourd'hui donc je pense que la
surenchère parfois qui est qui est
construite autour d'eux des politiques
d'immigration parfois ne valent pas ne
vaut pas la peine
parce que je pense que le problème est
ailleurs donc je pense que ce que le
gouvernement évoque aujourd'hui comme
constat est réel nous voyons très bien
depuis plusieurs années maintenant qu'
il n'y a pas une véritable politique
d'asile une politique migratoire au
niveau européen vous dites que le
problème vient d'ailleurs
oui voilà c'est à dire que il il faut
déjà partir sur le constat selon lequel
lorsqu'on vient solliciter l'asile dans
un pays européen
c'est bien parce que des personnes sont
en quête de liberté cela peut être une
liberté au plan politique cela peut être
une liberté au plan économique ou encore
une toute forme de liberté
en tout cas l'asile par principe n'est
pas un voyage d'agrément
ce sont des personnes qui sont en
situation de grande difficulté qui sont
exposés à des persécutions dans leur
pays qu'ils sont exposés à à la mort à
la torture donc qui fuit le danger est
donc lorsqu'ils viennent ce que ces
personnes arrivent en europe c'est bien
pour trouver un refuge où trouver une
protection internationale et donc je
pense que le problème doit être pris à
la base des pays d'où
c'est chaque les personnes douce s'exile
les personnes c'est le sens pour moi un
problématique est là donc les pays
d'origine de l'exil la france qui figure
au premier rang des pays d'accueil en
europe
je ne pense pas que françois nan je
pense que c'est exagéré je pense que
l'allemagne a fait la preuve aujourd'hui
de sa capacité d'accueil
en tout cas dans les les dernières
années nous avons vu avec le sang des
demandeurs d'asile imprécis oui oui mais
la france n'est pas indépendante est la
france n'est pas en tête la france veut
être en tête mais la france ne ferait
l'objet les objectifs qu'ils critiquent
en fait qu'elle s'assigne
nous avons l'objectif de 10 mille
migrants dont le cadre de la de la
réinstallation vous savez que la
réinstallation c'est un concept qui est
récent qui consiste à accueillir des
demandeurs d'asile qui ont déjà trouvé
asile dans les pays tiers c'est à dire
que l'on prend l'exemple du sahel je
prends l'exemple du moyen orient des
personnes qui ont besoin d'asile peuvent
trouver asile en jordanie peuvent
trouver asile en syrie en egypte ainsi
de suite et lorsque les capacités
d'accueil ne va là ne sont pas
suffisants et dans ces personnes font
recours à des pays européens notamment
la france l'allemagne l'italie ainsi de
suite et c'est là la question et je
pense que là c'est la réponse commence à
se mettre entrevue dans ce que dans ce
cadre-là dollars de la réinstallation
des demandeurs d'asile le nombre
croissant du nombre de demandeurs
d'asile justement et cela pose le
problème des conditions d'accueil
on est suffisamment on en a les moyens
aujourd'hui bon je pense que la france
est en train de se doter des moyens en
vue de répondre à la question de la
capacité d'accueil parce que aujourd'hui
par exemple 70 mille demandeurs d'asile
n'ont pas de lieu d'accueil de maths de
façon permanente
je pense que nous avons eu la nuit de la
solidarité en février 2019 à paris je
pense que vous souvenez il ya une
marotte donc la nuit de la solidarité a
fini en exergue
3600 personnes qui étaient sans abri qui
était dénigrons qui demandait l'asile en
france et qui était là et rend dans les
quartiers de paris et donc nous pensons
que effectivement là le problème de la
capacité d'accueil des migrants en
france et non seulement en france mais
en europe suppose
et c'est là aussi où la politique
européenne doit justement se doter des
moyens afin de financer les structures
d'accueil qui ce qui se diversifie et
qui sont très nombreuses en france nous
avons des cas d'aller les centres
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile et nous
avons aussi des structures d'hébergement
mais l'émergence ou vous voir évoquer
justement cette maraude est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment que les pouvoirs
publics vont de l'avant en matière
justement d'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile ah non non je pense qu à une
forte pression de la société civile les
associations qui sont très nombreuses et
sûrement qu'ils s'attèlent à travailler
dans la dent dans les structures
d'accompagnement des demandeurs d'asile
en tout cas la sonnette d'alarmé a été
sonné depuis plusieurs années quant à la
réponse que l'état devrait à apporter à
la question de l'accueil des migrants et
cette question demeure une question
épineuse mais j avoue qu' il ya des
efforts qui ont quand même été entrepris
mais il faudrait aller encore plus en
avant
merci beaucoup daniel 20 je rappelle que
vous êtes avocate au barreau de paris
merci beaucoup merci